Welcome to you.
It is wonderful to have you with us as we open the pages of establishing the Imam, working our way through the profound arguments laid out by the author.
We are at a crucial turning point in the text.
He now finds the imam hidden inside the everyday duties of Islam, so prayer, alms, and war quietly require him.
Take the imam away, and the prayer of the alms of the war do not lose a leader.
They fall void.
I mean, that is the core of it.
That is the entire anchor of the argument the author is building for us.
It really is.
He is taking the argument for the imam out of those abstract celestial realms of pure theology-like, the kinds of philosophical altitudes that are breathtaking but often feel removed from daily existence.
and he is dropping it squarely into the physical daily acts of the religion.
Yeah, exactly.
Because if we look at the preceding arguments the author made, they established what we might call the ceiling of his claim.
He argued methodically that the leader of the time is the absolute summit of the human world.
But the author understands human nature.
He knows that an argument resting solely at that high altitude
can feel utterly remote to the person living their everyday life.
Yeah, it runs the risk of being perceived as, just a beautiful piece of cosmic reasoning that never actually touches the ground you walk on.
Precisely.
So he brings it down to earth.
We were talking about the daily prayers, the handling of charity, the administration of justice in the courtroom, and well, the brutal reality of the battlefield.
The leader is the physical and spiritual hinge on which every single duty turns.
To build that case, to truly show how this authority is wired into our daily reality, the author actually starts at the absolute beginning of human experience.
He begins with a crisis of ignorance.
First principles.
We have to start with first principles.
Exactly.
A newborn baby knows nothing.
That is just an observable, irrefutable fact of biology.
Human beings arrive completely empty of knowledge.
It is a profound vulnerability.
And the author points out that scripture states this starting point without any softening at all.
We are brought forth from the wombs of our mothers, knowing absolutely nothing.
We are entirely destitute.
Utterly destitute.
And only afterward are we handed the instruments of learning, hearing, sight, and hearts.
So to prove that knowledge explicitly requires instruction, that it does not just spontaneously well up from our biology,
I love this part.
He asks us to consider the donkey's bray and the dog's bark.
It is such a striking comparison, focusing purely on what nature produces without any outside interference.
It is almost jarring, but I mean, it does exactly what it needs to do logically.
He says, if knowledge and speech came purely from nature, then human beings would speak perfectly by nature.
in the exact same way a donkey brays and a dog barks without anyone ever having to pull them aside and teach it to them.
Right, because nature never varies.
Exactly.
The braying of a donkey sounds identical whether you are standing in India or in the country of the Arabs.
The bark of a dog is exactly the same everywhere on earth.
It's programmed.
It belongs strictly to nature.
But human speech completely defies that uniformity.
It splinters into many tongues.
A child raised in one part of the world speaks an entirely different language than a child raised in another.
We do not have a universal natural bark.
No, we do not.
Because we must be taught this capacity for communication splinters based entirely on who is doing the teaching.
And knowledge behaves in the exact same way.
If it just welled up from nature, everyone on earth would know the exact same things equally.
Manifestly we do not.
We are completely dependent on being instructed.
And that dependency is the foundation stone of his entire proof.
Because if every single person must learn from another person, we are compelled by simple logic to follow that chain of instruction backward.
Link after link.
Link after link stretching back through time.
But reason dictates that a chain of human teachers cannot regress forever into infinity.
It must end somewhere.
It cannot simply end in just another human learner.
No, because then you are immediately forced to ask who taught them, and the chain just keeps going.
It must logically end in one who is taught by no human being at all.
It must end in someone who received knowledge through direct divine transmission.
The ultimate end point.
That final teacher who anchors the entire human chain
peace, our blessings of Allah be upon him and his family and the imam.
So our initial ignorance as human beings is completely deliberate then.
Like we are built to need this chain.
Utterly deliberate.
God made human beings ignorant by design.
If we were created already complete, there would be absolutely nothing to teach us, no moral reward to earn, and frankly, no wisdom in creating us to begin with.
Which leads us directly into the author's principle that the earth is never left empty of this guide.
Because if humanity requires a teacher to rescue us from our ignorance and to resolve our inevitable disputes, because human knowledge splinters, then removing that teacher leaves the whole community in chaos.
It creates A theological disaster regarding the justice of God.
It does.
We could stand before him and say, you designed us to need instruction, yet we found no one to guide us.
That is philosophically unthinkable.
So God's standing proof is always present.
As the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him, firmly established in his teachings, the earth is never empty of one who stands for God with the proof.
Yes.
Whether that figure is visible and widely recognized, or whether he is fearful and hidden from public view due to the dangers of the time, the proof is always physically present.
So we have established this absolute necessity for a defining center of knowledge.
And then the author takes a profound turn to illustrate how the center operates.
He introduces 3 symbols to explain the structure of this leadership.
The circle, the number one, and the dot.
Yes, he turns to geometry and mathematics to make a bold claim about the architecture of reality itself.
Let us look at the geometry first.
Among all the figures, the highest and most encompassing is the circle.
The circle is the DAA, the bounding figure, the circle of religion.
Every other shape can be logically and physically derived from the circle.
If you divide a circle, you can find a perfect square inside it.
Triangles emerge from its points.
Every other shape is contained within it, but the circle itself depends on absolutely none of them.
The traffic of dependency only runs one way.
The circle generates the square, but the square cannot generate the circle.
Exactly.
And the author applies this geometric absolute directly to the
the hierarchy of leadership.
The leader is the circle of religion.
He needs no other rank to justify his existence, but every other rank derives their reality entirely from him.
He runs this same logic through the science of numbers too.
The absolute foundation of all counting is the number one.
Two is just 1 + 1.
Every larger number depends entirely on the repetition of the unit, but the unit needs no other number to exist.
And then finally, the dot.
The finest symbol of all.
Philosophers describe the dot as having no parts, no extension, no width, no depth, yet it is the absolute origin of the line.
The line generates the surface, the surface generates the solid body.
Everything physically extended in the universe is generated from a point that has no extension at all.
That sounds like wordplay, reading the imam into every right after the fact.
It is very elegant poetry, taking geometry into numbers and mapping A theological hierarchy onto them, but it feels heavily contrived.
It feels like he has the conclusion
inclusion he wants to reach.
And he is just scouring mathematics for metaphors to justify it.
Is a fair challenge.
And the brilliant thing is that the author anticipates it entirely.
Oh, he sees it coming.
He knows that geometry can feel abstract.
Metaphors can be dismissed as intellectual tricks.
So he leaves the realm of shapes and numbers and walks us straight out of the academy and into the mosque.
He grounds the argument in the most basic, inescapable, daily physical gesture of Muslim worship.
The direction you face when you pray.
The Qabilah.
He asks us to look at the very language, the physical command itself.
The word Qibla comes from an Arabic root that means face to face.
To turn toward it is to set your face directly in front of something.
Intrinsically, yes.
And the root for being before something, standing in front of it and preceding it is the exact same root that forms the word imam.
I see.
The prayer leader is called that precisely because he stands before the rows and precedes them.
So the divine command to face forward in prayer is not merely geographical.
It is not just about aligning your body with coordinates on a map.
It is a command to orient yourself toward the one who goes before you.
When you turn your face forward in prayer,
You are performing in a physical miniature what your entire life of worship is meant to be, a deliberate turning of the self toward the one appointed to lead it.
I don't buy that yet a shared root doesn't make facing the Qibla an argument about who leads.
Languages share roots all the time through historical accident.
You cannot build a theological mandate for absolute infallible leadership just because two words share a few consonants in classical Arabic.
And again, the author is ready for that exact resistance.
He pushes much further than just etymology.
He moves from the direction of the prayer to the rigorous mechanics of the congregation itself.
Okay, let us look at the congregation.
Think about the well-known prophetic teaching that a prayer performed in congregation is worth 27 times a solitary prayer.
The author asks, where does that enormous multiplier come from?
Why such a massive difference in spiritual value?
Exactly.
He argues it is not simply the physical presence of a crowd that earns it.
God is not rewarding you just for standing shoulder to shoulder in a crowded room.
It stems entirely from the presence of the leader.
It stems from the fact that the prayers performed behind him, facing him, being led by him in intention as well as in physical action.
Let us actually unpack that requirement of intention because it is central to how the author views allegiance.
It is not just about moving your body when the leader moves his body.
Not at all.
It is a rigid, unforgiving spiritual discipline.
If A follower in the congregation copies the leader's movements exactly, bowing the moment he bows, prostrating the moment he prostrates,
but their inner intention is not completely joined to his leadership.
Their prayer is entirely void.
Wow.
I mean, if you consciously oppose the leader in a single bow, your prayer is broken.
You must start over.
The outward match of the physical limbs is completely worthless without the inward match of intention.
And this is a profoundly reciprocal relationship.
If the follower gives their intention completely, the leader becomes their guarantor.
The leader compensates for the follower's hidden negligence.
Yes, covering their internal lapses.
He carries the spiritual weight of what the follower inadvertently drops.
So the lesser case proves the greater case.
That is the logical leap.
If obedience to a mere local, fallible prayer leader is this weighty, if opposing him in a single physical gesture annuls your conversation with God,
then what must logically be the case with the supreme divine leader?
The author is saying the structure of the daily prayer is actually a working daily model of absolute allegiance.
It is training us.
A working model that scales up to every major public right.
He extends this same structural necessity of the Friday prayers.
He notes that the Friday congregation is entirely invalid without the sermon.
The KHU Bob.
Yes.
The prayer itself cannot occur without it.
And that sermon cannot be validly delivered except by the leader or his explicitly appointed representative.
Strip him away, and the community's central weekly gathering just dissolves into a meaningless gathering.
And he scales it up even further, taking us out of the local mosque and mapping this logic onto the ultimate journey.
pilgrimage.
The physical reality of where the Kaaba is located becomes a vital part of the proof for the nature of leadership.
The geographical setting is deeply intentional.
God placed his house in a barren desert, a valley entirely without cultivation, devoid of any worldly benefit or comfort.
Historically, a place reachable only through intense physical hardship.
Weariness, risk of harm from enemies and elements along the road.
When you think about it from a purely human perspective, why not put the absolute center of pilgrimage somewhere accessible, a place of peace and prosperity where worship could be conducted in comfort?
So that the pilgrim would understand that what the house truly symbolizes
can only be reached in the exact same way.
The leader is reached only through immense effort, endurance, and the absolute willingness to suffer for the journey.
Placing the Kaaba in a barren valley filters the motive of every single person who approaches it.
Guarantees the sincerity of the seeker.
The turning toward the leader must arise from pure faith alone.
never from greed or the pursuit of political prestige.
If it were in a lush city, people would flock there for trade and comfort, claiming it was for worship.
Exactly.
Every single exhaustive act of the pilgrimage points to affirming obedience to the leader under harsh conditions, seeking pure guidance.
Which brings us to a major structural pivot in the text.
We have spent time in these deeply personal acts of worship, the private intention of the prayer, the grueling physical endurance of the pilgrimage, but
Now we move into the heavy societal institutions of the community.
We are moving into the immense power of the treasury and the violence of the battlefield.
And here is where we see the structural necessity laid bare once again, staled up to the level of society and statecraft.
Take the imam away and the prayer, the alms and the war.
Do not lose a leader, they fall void.
Let us examine the alms, the purification of wealth.
The author deeply discusses the zakah and the homes.
He points to a very specific mandate regarding how this charity is historically collected.
The argument here turns on a profound detail in the Quranic command itself.
God did not tell the community to simply collect and distribute the alms amongst themselves, like a secular welfare program.
The command was explicitly directed to the prophet.
Take alms from their wealth to purify them and pray for them.
The purifying prayer of the receiver is the explicit, divinely mandated recompense for the alms given.
The giver hands over wealth and they receive the active spiritual intersection of the one appointed by God to take it.
But the prophet is gone.
Which creates a massive insurmountable theological problem if the office does not continue intact.
If that divine recompense was only granted to the believers who lived in his time and then strictly withheld from every generation born after.
God would be committing an egregious injustice.
He would be demanding the act under threat of punishment, but making the required reward entirely unavailable.
God is entirely far above such injustice.
Therefore, the function of receiving and purifying cannot die.
Only the living leader may lawfully collect the alms today because only his prayer can fulfill the divine recompense mandated in the original command.
And there is a second crucial clue regarding the nature of the alms.
They are strictly forbidden to the prophet and to his family.
They cannot personally benefit from the charity they collect.
It is a brilliant safeguard to prevent any accusation of personal worldly gain.
If he could enrich himself from the public homes.
cynical people could justifiably accuse him of inventing A rigorous duty just to live in luxury.
By absolutely forbidding the alms to him, it reveals exactly who the alms actually belong to, the office, the function of leadership.
But to compensate the family for being uniquely forbidden the common charity that sustains the poor, God assigned them instead the 5th.
The colognes.
Yes, a designated and separate share of the spoils.
This separates their sustenance
from the purification rights of the common believer's wealth.
Which brings us to the ultimate most severe power of the state, the waging of war and the control of the public treasure.
The stakes could not be higher here.
The author insists that war can only be lawfully waged under the banner of the leader.
Because only he possesses the infallible moral and practical authority that makes a war just, rather than just a massive sinful shedding of blood.
He alone guards the public treasury.
The Bait Al-Mah.
It is under his absolute incorruptible guarantee.
In the chaos of war, he's the only one who holds the divine knowledge required to distinguish a violently irredeemable rebel from a rightful believer who has simply erred.
He knows precisely who to
pardon, who to ransom from captivity with the funds of the treasury, and how to protect the borders?
And the believers who fight under his command are guaranteed salvation, but only as long as they maintain their wa laa.
Their inward unbreakable bond of allegiance.
Break that bond of allegiance.
And just like breaking your intention in the middle of the daily prayer, the entire effort becomes futile.
A war fought without that bond is just murder.
We have reached a point where we have to address the counter-argument.
The author is methodically dismantling his opponents.
And to truly understand his brilliance, we need to look honestly at the rival jurists.
The 4 SUNY school founders.
Let us steel man their position.
We must acknowledge that they were not just sitting around inventing rules for their own amusement.
They built vast, deeply functional legal frameworks.
They did.
They constructed systems of jurisprudence that literally held empires together for centuries, structuring everything from complex inheritance laws to marriage
contracts to the severe laws of blood and retribution.
No serious scholar denies that they constructed monumental systems of civil and religious law.
But the author does not attack the complexity of their systems.
He bypasses the branches and attacks the foundational root of their authority.
He presents a sharp trap, forcing them onto a devastating fork of their own making.
He looks at what these rival authorities actually claim in practice.
They claim supreme authority over the gravest matters of human life.
They adjudicate bloodshed, they distribute property, they lead the masses in prayer.
Yet by their own documented admission in their own legal texts, they concede they are not to be trusted with the collection and distribution of the alms.
It is a stunning contradiction.
Wait, we really need to pause and explain that deeply.
They trust themselves with the power of execution.
They trust themselves with dividing mass of estates, but they publicly declare they cannot be trusted with charity.
Exactly.
And the author forces the fork immediately.
Either their concession is true or it is false.
If it is true, if these leaders genuinely cannot be trusted with the charity of the believers, then they are not legitimate leaders at all.
They are, by definition, thieves.
And if they are thieves, it is entirely unlawful to pray behind them, unlawful to fight a war under their command, and absolutely unlawful to accept their severe rulings on blood and property.
You cannot let a self-admitted thief sentence a man to death.
But if the concession is false.
If the leaders are in fact honest and the accusation that they cannot be trusted is a deliberate lie, then the jurists who are bearing public witness to their authority while peddling this lie are liars.
And in any court of law, the testimony of a known liar is completely void.
The structure collapses either way.
The foundation crumbles under its own contradictory weight.
Couldn't this just be a pragmatic division of labor?
Perhaps they're just separating civil administration from religious purity.
A secular ruler
handles the messy business of borders and taxes, and the religious scholars handle the pristine purity of worship.
That is the pragmatic defense, yes.
Empires have used it for centuries.
It doesn't have to be a fatal theological contradiction.
It could just be necessary delegation to keep the religion surviving in a complex empire.
But the author points out
that this supposed division of labor results in a devastating chorus of contradictions, particularly when it comes to the administration of law.
How so?
He references the father of imams who painted a searing portrait of a judge operating under this splintered system.
He describes a man taking his seat in the court to decide a case completely adrift in doubt.
An obscure, complex case is brought to him.
And because he lacks true, divinely guaranteed knowledge, because he is just a scholar guessing in the dark, he pads his ruling with his own opinion.
He guesses, he uses analogy.
And while he projects absolute certainty outward, the wrong blood he is unjustly shed and the missed part of the states he is wrongly divided cry out against him to God.
Because the law splinters without a single infallibility.
It is exactly the same as human speech splintering into many tongues without the original teacher.
The exact same dynamic, but with eternal stakes.
One of the four SUNY school founders looks at a case and says a man should be executed.
Another looks at the exact same case and says he should be pardoned.
Four masters, 4 completely different verdicts on a single question of blood.
This is what passes for settled knowledge when the civil and the religious are divorced.
And this fatal flaw becomes most glaringly obvious when we look at the prescribed penalties, the hue dude, the amputations, the stonings.
The gravest, most irreversible punishments in the sacred law.
The author notes that even his opponents agree on the fundamental rule here.
A man without lawful, legitimate authority cannot impose these penalties.
A vigilante cannot cut off a thief's hand.
It requires absolute legitimate authority.
Furthermore, by the opponent's own established rules of jurisprudence, a judge must be righteous.
A known sinner cannot judge a case.
And a known sinner's testimony is utterly inadmissible in court.
Okay, I see the trap.
If they concede that an unjust leader forfeits authority and a sinner's testimony is void, they disqualify themselves from administering the law.
They are caught in the web of their own legal definitions.
They hand him the verdict on their own terms.
It is the ultimate collapse of their argument.
The author is basically reading their own rule book back to them.
If a judge who betrays his trust must be removed from the bench, how can these rulers and jurists who openly admit their own flaws possibly administer the supreme laws of life and death?
They disqualify themselves.
They built the court, established the rules of evidence, and then proved they are unfit to sit on the bench.
So because the claimants logically disqualify themselves by their own rigorous rules, the authority must reside elsewhere.
It cannot just disappear.
It inherently inevitably falls to the purified progeny of THR and
the family uniquely protected from corruption, intrinsically purified of falsehood, who actually possess the continuous divine knowledge required to stand without contradiction at the absolute summit of the law.
They are the only ones who can execute the law without the blood crying out against them.
Because their knowledge is not guesswork, it is inheritance.
This brings the entire argument back to you, the listener.
What we have been exploring today is the classical Ismaili reading of the law of society
and of reality itself.
It is a comprehensive framework where the outward acts of your life, the physical prayer you offer, the monetary charity you give, the grueling pilgrimage you endure,
are entirely worthless without the inward allegiance they were explicitly built to carry.
They are shells waiting for a core.
Take the imam away, and the prayer, the alms, and the war do not lose a leader, they fall void.
We leave you with this provocation, a real question to mull over as you step back into the dust of your daily life.
Where do you perform the outward rites of your life while quietly withholding the loyalty they were meant to express, and what would bringing those two things together cost you this week?